boom alright I am here with Alan sake on
a man who realized this we need to
update society's code for our tech has
evolved but our hearts certainly haven't
the deeper you connect to earth the more
you get it and he speaks to many great
minds within the synthesis of science
and spirituality has been as well as
being well-rounded in internal they're
covering the world's most pressing
pressing topics with a focus on
stewardship of the earth and assistant
synthesis of multidisciplinary knowledge
doing his part to ever so awaken aspects
of humanity to its collective union with
evolution creating an opening knowledge
database and providing equal degree of
economic freedom for everyone
to self-actualize I like this term self
actualize this is great this is like
early kind of life coach self-help talk
from the early 90s I love it it's great
it's a good term actually what it was
also used in as well was life spring I
don't know if you remember life spring
from the 70s which was a stealth
actualizes a great word anyway but it's
good to have you here but I'm we're
recording this episode of my podcast in
person and it's been a while since I did
a person episode well and we're also
it's nice to have a visual component to
it as well so fun
so dude it's great to talk to you but I
always love our conversations I really
appreciate you doing the research on the
the small bits that I write on like my
website where I I do try and explain
some of the most important pieces to who
I am and what I hope to bring as a gift
yeah what you're all about yeah yeah
thank you for finding that yeah you know
one thing that you're very good at but
is you're very good at putting yourself
out there so I was gonna kind of
initially ask ask you that then my next
question is gonna be you know you talk
to a lot of people and the network's
that you've gained from that but do you
want to speak a little bit to the origin
of you putting yourself out there and
how it's come to be that you've had so
many one-on-one relationships with
people many of which have been recorded
like when did you first initially start
kind of putting yourself out there
well there is definitely this process
that many people feel with being so
hesitant to put themselves out there and
that didn't resonate with me because I
from a young age just began putting
myself out there and that's why the
transition to doing these video was no
problem but even in the young times
being so like relentless with growth
through experience of putting myself out
there so came in a different a couple of
different modalities um one of them was
a like growing through the fear of
approaching somebody and being rejected
sure yeah I was though that was probably
one of the big ones if not the biggest
one is just um going through so many
tens of thousands of permutations of the
first encounters that uh you just you'd
no longer take it personally when it
like doesn't resonate with someone else
and so that was the that was probably
the big one and that was also a big part
of like me um learning sales and I'm
trying to give give give people things
that that they may not have ever heard
about and maybe resonate with with them
hmm and it's funny to most people when
they a lot of people never have heard
their voice recorded much and they don't
like their voice when they first hear it
right so I think you have to get over
that barrier too
like I don't like the way I sound so in
your early days I'm sure that as you
recorded yourself many times through
many conversations we'll get into what
you're doing but that's something that
is definitely another hurdle or obstacle
to get over it's like encountering
others or initially corresponding with
others about what you're doing and that
you want to talk to them about the
deeper things of the world and then also
feeling like you're nervous about the
way that you present yourself in doing
so here's another way of framing this is
that if you truly have done the self
work where you love yourself for me to
look back two years ago to the Alan that
was doing these that was nowhere near as
if all of this I am now I'm still in
love with that exact moment that was
captured even though I was way less
aware and way less conscious away
less-evolved that's so funny because
that's so true is you're also
documenting your imperfections and I've
said many good things on podcast and
some of them are publicly available in
some of them but it's all on the record
right and you have to not be afraid of
learning through experience through
conversation and having it be on the
record as the Internet is written in ink
as they say yeah so that's another
element of not being afraid of oh my
first initial interviews are not good or
the conversations I had or that the
questions I asked somebody we're not as
rubbish but you look through the
evolution of self as you do these
processes and you will get better when
you see that you see that I mean you two
years ago is not very long ago not very
long ago come come wait look come come
come yeah I come with swing it in my
dear friend and colleague has joined us
yes I just had our good friend about him
putting himself out there and the many
you know the aspects of not being afraid
of your early days of being an
interviewee or being interviewed and
talking to so many people about it and
early things that people are our theory
okay I have this interview in 2010 at a
Maps conference I stare
that's with gypsy told who does my naked
truth and you do the interview nude and
so I'm at this meta conference or out in
the foyer and outside of the thing and
now just like yeah okay okay it was in
public yeah so we get out gear off and
they're like the the Hyatt Regency all
the stuff come on they're looking and
they're like and it's like yeah that's
how I bury that interview that there's
somewhere that's funny yeah you can you
can find it I think if you google that
be different who is naked at a studio
but if you're publicly naked that's a
little different
especially yeah that's funny but um you
know you've talked to a lot of people
man so why don't you give a little bit
of insight as to what you're doing these
days and how the kind of evolution of
your conversations the many earlier when
I saw you today you said something that
you've interviewed almost a thousand
people is that correct in four years ago
were you in the last four years Allen's
interviewed almost a thousand people are
over a thousand people so I think of
some of these seminal interviewers you
know like maybe Jeffrey Mishlove or
Charlie Rose or Terry Gross and they
seem to be very know it learned people
just through these many conversations
they've had because when you listen to a
podcast or listening to a conversation
you kind of get down low it's kind of
but there's nothing quite like actually
having the conversation it's almost like
having the experience so speak a little
bit to like how much you've evolved and
learned through your like I can't
imagine how much you've learned through
a thousand interviews yeah earlier we
were we were mentioning how important it
is to be completely both like fearless
and also in love with the approach of
engaging another person in conversation
no matter what their responses and not
taking it personally if it doesn't
resonate with them so through training
tens of thousands of iterations just
like your greatest deep learning
algorithms do today when you do tens of
thousands of these iterations with
people with looking at their eyes with
feeling their emotional states and
having empathy building relationships
with other people by caring about who
they are genuinely and and trying to see
what path they are to their to the what
gifts they're bringing to the world and
seeing how you can assess seeing how
they can assist you so that has been so
instrumental since my earliest days of
caring about these tens of thousands of
iterations yeah but people people and
their unique gifts are are such we were
talking about this in our last episode
that nature is the best teacher and that
what is nature humans are nature and
humans have these great big catalogs of
libraries stored within them of
experiences with the families and their
friends and their jobs and what they
care about and their their experiences
of ego death and interconnectedness and
if you know how to socialize with other
people well from heart to heart and ask
these questions about the depths of the
psyche you can learn the best like the
most nutritious textures of experience
and so it's so a big part of me starting
it also was several years ago now it's
been probably almost five years ago I
realized that there was nothing
supercool going on on the streets where
people were just taking a camera and a
mic and just going like you know what
impact do you want to make in the world
right and and so I was just like I'm
gonna be that guy so did you start kind
of your the interview processes through
this almost candid I don't wanna say
ambush journalism is cold walked up
maybe cold walk up to people that was
shows that show is called practice happy
and if people want to dive in you can
still find some of the archive videos on
on my website and stuff but yeah it
would be great and I remember
on hill one of the most profound
responses was that he told me what about
making an impact on the University told
me when I was 22 he told me you're not
just here to solely have fun but you
have an obligation to enrich humanity
you have an obligation as rigid as the
world there's the world exactly that's
the problem with so much of like robot
cultures people just want to be
mindlessly entertained and we all love
entertainment here and there you know
I'll watch a great film or you know
stupid fun TV show but most of it's very
fluff and very low resonant and very few
people spend their spare time learning
things and improving themselves so to be
in an area where we find a element of
wanting to spend our time doing
something that fuels our true nature but
also is enriching to others is a special
thing and I think that you're trying to
do that through having higher level
discussions and discourse with people
and it took a while to evolve there
because from that days of its Aries
because well remember we're talking
about all these permutations of tens of
thousands of experiences well what
happens is just like with sales when you
go door-to-door and try and bring
someone to something that they may enjoy
yeah that what happens is once you get
so many of the doors slammed in your
face you build immunity to taking things
personally but then there's also with
when you do door to door if somebody
does really enjoy what you're bringing
to them and offering them you're getting
their their social security number to
test their credit you're getting their
credit card information cyma so you
build a really in just a couple minutes
a really strong relationship with
somebody in a short amount of time and
then same thing with this ambush
journalism thing is that when you go and
you want to like hey I have a couple
interesting questions I want them asking
people when people tell you get away
from me like then that builds resilience
for you because you don't take to take
it personally you laugh at it we were
laughing at it when those things were
happening fix it then there were people
that would literally sit with
for half an hour and they would start
crying about their the fact that
somebody stopped them in the middle of
the busyness of the san francisco
chaoticness and started asking them
questions about the deepest emotion
they've ever felt and then they started
opening up to us about grief and why
grief is so important and how they have
a community around grief and how there's
not enough people that will openly be
willing to talk to me about my mother
passing and what and that type of thing
cuz we're all so busy and running around
and so hearing this also at 22 just
stopping random people and having that
then that evolved to doing things like
having mmm watching a lot of like in
Neil deGrasse Tyson and Carl Sagan who
were big about science communication and
so that was very inspiring to me albeit
science and spirituality both have their
own ways of harmonizing that I'm
actually really honed in on now but that
the the idea of being able to simplify
something as complex as the inner life
of a cell or something like the way that
planetary orbital dynamics work in some
sort of a fashion of like can i
laconically put it in just a couple
metaphors or analogies that awaken you
to the beauty of the cellar the atom
where the planets and so that's what
also sparked a fire under my butt to
start being like okay you're a famous
neuroscientist you guys are
up-and-coming comedians right and so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna host
the science comedy show it's called
Eureka we're gonna have the comedian sit
over here I'm gonna be a host and a
moderator between the science and the
comedy and we're gonna make this a game
show and we're gonna ask the audience a
live like hundred seat theater audience
these questions from neuroscience or
biotech or astrophysics or whatever
blockchain and crypto fields that it may
be cannabis psychedelics and so it was
great to have this sort of interactive
game show style of people getting to to
laugh learn and so then that opened up
many doors because it started being like
okay well who do I know now in this
field now they connected me to these
people and guess what
that became the rolodex for sourcing the
guests for this program and so yeah I'm
the same thing with world's fair so
there was a period of time where I was
also helping produce a speaker staged at
at the conferences between New York and
San Francisco where we had thousands of
people attending these future vessels to
try and get inspired the key word is
inspired to build and so I was curating
the speaker stages and so again I was
curating people to come and give you
know 15 20 minute talks on the speaker
stages again that became the rolodex
again simulation was about little over
two years ago was this obsession with
all of these thought-provoking questions
and writing them down and sending them
out to all these leaders that would have
been mentioning and then doing something
like getting responses from them and
realizing that why is there no there's a
Joe Rogan experience in LA where he sits
down with different leaders in the
Hollywood area in the LA area but the
Silicon Valley has so many great minds
there's no one on one talk show in
Silicon Valley yet and so I was like
we're gonna take this profound list of
questions we're gonna take this one on
one talk show daily format and we're
just gonna combine those and start doing
it and that's why around October 2017
was our like first live event that we
did another live event and then it
turned into a daily show where we
actually started doing it daily with all
these different people and sometimes we
would do two shows or up to three shows
in one day sometimes we'd go a week at a
conference without doing a show but so
that's how this build up of like 650
including our backlog of content right
now in the last two years of interviews
that are that we've been learning from
and most recently I was telling you both
on the walk here into the studio that
after going through these tens of
thousands of permutations of one-on-one
human individual interaction plus trying
to dive into the depths of their psyches
plus doing these thousand plus
interviews and these interactions from
ambush journalism to the science comedy
show to the to the speaker stages to the
one-on-one
here on this program it's time to slow
down and find the most important
profound teachings that people have been
teaching over the last couple of years
and so to find the patterns to find the
most unique ways of communing with the
one trying to make that relatable
disseminate that try and make that
relatable trying to awaken more people
around the world and so that's really
this next big chapter is disseminating
through multimedia these profound
learnings and so that's the yeah cool so
that's that's an interesting broad
overarching the last few years for you
and it's funny to see how things involve
a lot of those conferences and stuff can
be very inspiring you know when you get
to some annual event that people put a
lot of time and effort into to do
something and you're there with people
on your same wavelength and resonate
with whatever the field and you go away
and you you you have this thing in
you're pumped and it's like yeah this is
great it was a meeting of excellent
minds doing cool things that are maybe
all over the world and we haven't had as
much interaction and we're in person
those conferences can be exactly what
you mentioned man but I have a slight
superficial question in this kind of is
for both of you we'll start with Alan is
that I have found that sometimes I
suffer from not being seen that much you
know you can be this voice that's heard
but I have my wonderful and amazing
colleague Rach here who we do a show
together and Rach is seen on camera and
people know him and recognize him so
what brought you to have the show we
have a video component was it that
aspect of also being seen because people
identify very much with the face and
seeing people and I think when you see
some of these very like the world's
biggest podcast in the universe are also
a video podcast because people really
resonate was seeing the face and seeing
people talk and in the sense of me to
that egocentricity like the Joe Rogan
show the Tim Ferriss show you know the
names are in there it's very much about
them being the conduit for the
information but it seems like when
somebody's watching Tim Ferriss or you
know even you're so a lot of people will
bias towards watching simulation because
to just see the faces talking even
though there's obviously just an RSS
feed a podcast audio only compiled
so what do you got yeah what are your
thoughts about that I'll hit you back
some interesting thoughts about that so
actually when it first you know we were
talking like five years ago why even
take the camera why not just take the
mic on to the streets right what was
really alive is the distribution methods
how badly do you want to catalyze
awakening because if you really want to
catalyze awakening you will not choose
solely audio and I had two years ago or
so I had an in-person international Sam
Harris where I told him that why are you
not doing video as well you have this
opportunity of goldmine of distributing
across YouTube and Facebook and LinkedIn
video Twitter video Instagram video now
tick-tock and snapshot on video Billy
Billy if you want to go to China which
is I'm listing platforms that we
distribute on right now and it's because
if you want to catalyze the awakening
meet people where they're at across
different platforms plus give them the
video component which gets them deeper
into your soul when you get somebody to
look at Niles or Rach sharing what you
shared on this last episode when they
look at your eyes while you share your
mannerisms all that type of stuff
yeah they dive deeper into who you
actually are and so but that's if they
can sometimes because we do still of
course share across SoundCloud iTunes
Spotify stitcher etc on on audio
sometimes people who listen when they're
whatever working out or in the car or
whatever so sometimes people don't get
that but the video component but to make
it broadly distributive across those
platforms is a key and so that's
something I've carried over the last
five years of broad distribution albeit
in the most recent it's not we only
landed on tick-tock a couple of months
ago we only landed on Billy Billy a
Chinese like YouTube style like a couple
months ago so so but we keep adding and
there's a lot of a lot of work with only
a couple people that help us part-time
to distribute this so
that's also a big question is where are
your greatest numbers of efficacy so if
you catalyzed more of the awakening
through the way that you're packaging
shamans of the global village and
distributing that where it's specific
around purchasing that pisode that took
you guys so much of your souls to
actually make then that is your unique
distribution method that may be
catalyzing the greatest amount of
awakening but then can you juxtapose
that simultaneously with what would
happen if you did open source and rely
on other forms of financing it how many
more people couldn't awaken if it was
open source who knows those answers
that's why our contents never pay walled
because we'd never want to even enter
into that sphere where the things that
we're learning are always freely and
creative commons lee redistributable
across other people's networks in
platforms of music now on that angle how
have you found the potential for
sponsorship or advertising that is
amenable to these ideas and is that is
there an audience enough that it creates
a demographic that the advertisers can
see that there's either a niche market
or a gestating community which will
support their products and if they're
ethical products that align with the
community which also helps the awakening
right every crack that month it has to
be ethically aligned yeah it has to be
ethically line you're not gonna sell
advertisements for like a [ __ ]
missile guidance system I've been
listening to the jargon polka is like
and the first six minutes either for
mine advertisers or no in depth you know
download about the ad yeah Underpants is
there gonna undo pants and they're like
timber that lease has like a high
caliber of advertisers of Fame but in
like that's where the money is I guess
one of my favorite podcasts is you know
two cult podcast and they literally
advertise from like a cult book shops
you know that you can find their niche
and advertising but it's it's truf man
because you're doing something that all
three of us have had our shows and
various resources and it's like yeah how
do you interface slightly with commerce
enough to make it somewhat sustainable
that you get
a little bit or a lot so you just you
just say it you just said a big key
there which is this interfacing with
Commerce side of it because yeah that's
that's the big key because of Commerce
because here's a way of viewing it right
we find ourselves in the middle of
Silicon Valley where everyone and their
mother is talking about venture capital
or angel money to raise for their
businesses and this the same things
happening in New York and all these
other places where it's all about the
raise the financial raise give me the
million dollar round and then I'll hire
the people and I'll build the idea if
you talk to any venture capitalist or an
angel investor that's actually worth
their salt what they'll tell you is that
actually only a very small percentage of
ideas art businesses science projects
all this type of thing are actually
worth venture capital or angel
investment so another thing to keep in
thought is that same sort of paradigm
applies to the art that we're making as
well where sometimes it's not about
niles
and iraq getting a hundred thousand
dollars so that they can build episode
three with faster with another person to
help on the team and then to make the
awakening happening faster sometimes yes
that can be interesting to look into and
see if that can actually catalyze the
future you want it's also very beautiful
to realize that michelangelo took three
years to sculpt the Statue of David that
these things are not instant
gratification oriented which you guys
obviously know because these episodes
are take a long time so the idea is you
know him being patron by the Medici
family there's actually a good amount of
wisdom that exists in the ways that the
tree systems the large trees sequester
additional carbon distri
that across their roots and fungal
networks the smaller trees and seedlings
that don't sequester as much that same
process of redistribution of inclusive
stake holding is not where our existing
wealth infrastructure is like whatsoever
we have radical inequality because we
don't follow that same paradigm that
nature follows so arts like what we're
discussing this show your show many of
the other you'll see this coming up more
frequently but scientists are now
finding alternative funding methods
because how do you fund someone that's
trying to figure out Alzheimer's or or
cancer or any of these other things
where it's not something that's
investable to get some sort of a payout
and there's also a lot of cancer with
cancerous methodologies in that same
space with building molecules to trying
the array of cancer were actually
cancers apoptosis many of the times
occurs through very ancient modalities
like fasting or other ascetic behaviors
that can actually kill cancers early so
point being is that there's so many
fields art science spirituality that are
actually don't fit into the commerce
model and that we have to be willing to
admit that I don't want I don't want you
guys to sell your episodes I don't want
the show to be reliant on advertisers I
want people that are literally buying
their 12th house in the Bay Area where
their third yacht or their fifth Rolex I
want to wake them up so instead of
buying that property in the bay where
there could be three artists living in
that property and then being able to
work inside of the network effect of
growing their art instead that house is
bought like a game of Monopoly it's it's
[ __ ] empty along with their other ten
houses while they live in only one of
them 95% of the time
we have a crisis happening around the
patronage the needing to patron arts and
sciences and spiritual leaders and
create the functional cohesive inclusive
stake holding social fabric that makes
it fun for people to do so I bought the
domain rich patrons calm I haven't built
it out but that's a night that's here
that's something I'm very serious about
remember I was telling you guys before
we started that something that I'm doing
us I take this research and execution
sabbatical is that I also deeply care
about putting shamans of the global
village and all of my other friends that
we've had on the show that have that are
doing really profound things up on a
site maybe it is the rich patrons
dot-com site where all these people go
and then I direct my friends our friends
and other people's friends that have
millions of dollars to this site for
them to go and donate hundreds or
thousands of dollars to the people or
maybe even have a housing component
where they say yeah I have a fifth house
in the New York City area that I don't
use and so here I'll open up two of the
bedrooms for artists or spiritual
leaders to come and do their art there
because it's not just about going to the
mountain and doing your spiritual
communion at the mountain but it's about
coming back to civilization with your
enlightenment and with that wisdom
awakeness and then sharing it to the
others that then you can inspire them to
go on their own journeys to commune with
that one and so that I think is this
whole financial [ __ ] show that we find
ourselves in with art and science and
another one of the big aspects is it of
it is if you have 20,000 subscribers on
a channel like what we have here if
every single one of them potentially I
probably subscribe a simulation to maybe
a hundred or two hundred channels we
probably subscribe to you on YouTube I
am down to pay every single one of those
channels one dollar per month I will pay
all 100 to 200 channels that we
subscribe to one one dollar per month if
you paid one dollar per month to every
channel that you subscribe to our
channel would be getting $20,000 a month
mm-hmm it's interesting I was hearing an
old-school podcaster name see I'm a kmo
who had who has a podcast called the sea
realm say that like 10 plus years ago
then you would never have to watch an ad
and you'd never have to watch an ad -
because there ya know said something to
the extent of like if everybody that
listen to my podcast gave me a dollar
it'd be my full-time revenue you know
and it's a very decentralized way of
looking at it and on that front I I know
somebody that's a carpenter in Marin
County California and he worked for a
guy recently who owns literally every
house on one Street that's like five or
six house Street and the guy's a dick so
you know that's not making that guy
happy by being a god zillionaire who's
grossly off balanced in his way that he
chooses to spend his money and material
overload and excess and yes there's a
lot of wealthy people who do spend money
and more intelligent in excellent ways
fueling the being a patron of the arts
to some extent and a lot of people that
are so wealthy gets so much money that
they literally need to spend it to you
know not wasted and for tax purposes and
stuff annually so there are revenues
where you sometimes occasionally see
people being patron in ways by either a
centralized source or even better in
decentralized ways so I think it is
mature of you do to say that through a
lot of our struggles and commerce that
you're kind of playing the long game
with the show about how can this be
something that I'm giving and in other
ways getting back for maybe not directly
immediately just financial but spreading
insights that I care about through
conversations that I would want to have
and then also hopefully having ways that
it can continue to be sustained either
earlier through a salary or much later
so it's so important for people to not
fall especially as artists into those
rabbit holes of I need money I need
money money money because it actually
takes so much away from the process of
the creation of the Arts in those early
stages where you just truly have to pull
a hardcore dedication to your arts where
we definitely don't want people living
without clean water and and and good
healthy nutritious food where they're
sacrificing so much they don't even have
a roof over their head to be the artist
but that that we have to really take
into idea the way that art and science
of spirituality will kind of interact
and engage with commerce in new ways
that are that are actually more about
the Ascension and the in the process of
enlightenment and awakening through
those modalities and not so much about
the quote unquote embedded growth
obligations which is a term that Eric
Weinstein talks about a lot about the
economic obligation that all these mega
corporations have and universities have
and even the show could have if we
weren't smart enough to realize that we
don't want to follow that method we
don't have an embedded growth where we
have to have a staff of 20 engineers and
20 videographers and 20 editors and we
need 10 million dollars a year like you
can be a puzzle piece that is only that
is a channel of a hundred thousand
people that are watching the content you
don't need to be a twenty million person
channel so there's all these different
ways of viewing the harmonization of
Commerce and the next stages of
economics with spirituality science and
art yeah not being so top-heavy and what
you do I think about like something like
where the Bay Area hair is we're
recording this conversation and
Salesforce is this mega-monster company
that has like some 40,000 employees and
I hear about how you know 10,000 more
10,000 of them every day or just a
meetings and so you have these very
top-heavy organizations where it's like
oh we were in the meeting about the
meeting before the meeting today it's
like I don't want to say do all those
people really need to be employed there
but when you have a smaller more
autonomous company that is bottom-up
that's something like what you're doing
or what you know we're doing with our
show it's it's able to be sustained with
much less resources and I often times
think about well if you had infinite
resources even financially and you can
just have you know massive mega Bitcoin
and have endless capital what would you
doing with your face I think you'd
probably be doing this show if you were
you know a God zillionaire writer and
still want to be doing this show so it's
kind of like that's finding your purpose
in life which I know sounds a little
Wiggy but like that's right finding what
you authentically want to be doing what
would you be doing if you got infinite
well if you'd be doing something similar
to what you're doing now and yeah that
is that says a lot yes
yeah that's a great way to put it and
also just one other thought around this
topic that rung a bell is that when we
see all of these great minds that are
having conversations with other great
minds like these like these keynote
fireside chats that happen like it kind
of reminds me a bit of when like Marc
Benioff talked to Tim Cook right at one
of the at the recent Salesforce event
that's what triggered this I'm watching
the talk and I'm like these two could be
talking about such more profound things
that can catalyze way more awakening in
our world and so one of the big things
about this program as well is how do we
make these most first principled
questions about the nature of this
reality so deeply a part of the essence
of not only the public at large but also
the leaders at all of these companies
and nations around the world where they
themselves become like at the UN talking
about it at the World Economic Forum
talking about this at Davos at at that
fireside chat with Tim Cook and Marc
Benioff I we just listed where they
themselves are talking about it because
when they're talking about how much
sales how much sales forces is being
used at Apple and how much Apple
products are being used at Salesforce
it's like it's all like you might never
have so much control over so many
people's world views and perspectives
that if you would just but that's part
of the grand challenge that we're going
through anyway I know you probably have
you know ultimately that's what it's all
about and I say if you control the
narrative you can steer it not just the
conversation but the consciousness which
can see
if you limit that and they're just
talking about the mundane things then
people on us who say awakening that is
reinforced into the capitalist ideology
and so the value of these conversations
as you so astutely said as well it's
just like in nature we've got to go back
to that reciprocal energetic exchange
where the mother tree is nurturing with
the nutrients the other trees that need
it in an ecosystem which is coal feeding
itself and so the the ecology of ideas
which is generated here has the
potential to capitalize the
consciousness awakening and there's a
you know there's a very short type of
window of his story of history where
we've got one shot at this awakening and
so time is short and if you control the
narrative then you are sucking the
oxygen out of the room if it's not about
things which are important so these
conversations is what are what is
important as human beings you know that
place in the in the in the web of life
yeah and that's what I appreciate about
appreciate about your show Ellen is that
we don't feel like you can't talk about
real [ __ ] on your show it's important to
be able to have a real conversation
right and that like we just discussed
you should we just have had a previous
podcast before recording this one and
Alan was pumped and so you should have a
good you should feel great after a good
enriching conversation and I know people
that you know don't really talk to other
family members much or it's this very
dim little resident don't cry don't ask
a lot of questions and to talk about
etymology of words with like his story
history you know we talk we look at the
word asking which is really as King
right you do when you stand as king when
you ask questions so there's nothing
like from his teacher-student
relationship of being a wise elder and
having a student that is asking great
questions and you're applying practices
put into place by the teacher and this
teacher-student dynamic yeah so you
certainly or somebody dude that has
formulated a lot of questions in your
life and you you're essentially here
what your job is is you're a
professional of question asker
and you've formulated I know this list
of really juicy questions over the years
do you want to speak to that a little
bit yeah
yeah it's it's questions um the Tony
Robbins said that the quality of your
life is the quality of your questions
and I really resonate with that quote
that if you and which kind of also ties
us into like when you know how to
interface with these tens of thousands
of permutations of unique one-on-one
human experiences if you can go
heart-to-heart and then if you can ask a
question that makes the person feel like
you genuinely care about them and it's a
question that interests them people love
talking about themselves and they have
so many stories that they can share
about themselves but you have to have
the genuine love and care and interest
in passing an hour learning about that
like you'll Michelangelo with the Statue
of David Rees as each question sculpts
them to reveal their essence so how long
does it take you have this master list
of ultimate questions is that been as
you've done many many hundreds if not
over a thousand interviews you've kind
of cherry picked ones that have been
you've really gotten juicy nuggets out
of an air list some of these great
questions yeah yeah yeah that list it's
great because that list is though it's
linked in every single episode we've
ever done it's always it like the
towards the bottom in our like list of
links so people can always go and find
the list and it's interesting because
the list the evolution of the list over
time is also cool because a lot of the
questions initially two years ago were
not about the nature of reality so
people know the truth that it's not Alan
two years ago asking people about the
nature of reality that the truth is it's
Alan at age twenty seven just in the
last couple of months that has been so
obsessed with it that now it's every
episode is at least trying to probe into
that and and trying to probe into this
most upstream or root issue which is our
feelings of separation and our lack of
interconnectedness so this alan is only
a couple months old those that follow
the show know that
and so it's also important to be honest
about that evolution and to never try
and like fish back and like say like Oh
up on a pedestal because I was thinking
about this years ago
so the questions two years ago were
about you know about like how do we go
through the process of actually creating
us another space settlement like if we
go to the Moon and Mars what do you do
is it like the first person that lands
there gets to become the [ __ ] owner
of it and they get to like run the
government of it right and how long till
we play talked of it out there
yeah yeah it cetera and so so like these
were like the questions are like like
genetic engineering and neuro technology
was a big question two years ago for me
cuz I was like who the [ __ ] is gonna get
access to this we figure out who gets to
edit their intelligence their metabolism
their eradicate diseases and I was like
this is like because I'm literally
learning from all these brilliant people
about this and then I go why are we
talking about the ethics the philosophy
the morals the spiritual side of all
these things and so that was this again
this massive what I felt was in balance
to bring up the ethics philosophy morals
spiritualism with the advance of the
science and the technology and so that's
really kind of what I guess you could
even say my root my roots two years ago
were harder on the sciences and the
technologies and then over the last
couple of years it literally turned to
the ethics and the morals and the
philosophies and the spiritual
spirituality rising up with it and
meeting it and so that's why you know
albeit I did sit like my first 10-day
meditation retreat the passion of when I
was 23 so about four years ago but even
then I needed that like I needed that
footing and I think probably like five
Meo DMT was also around that time for my
first uhm experience and so the
combination of those things as well was
literally this tapping into what I
didn't know was the word the ultimate
nature of reality or like Nirvana or
what
people want to call it not really having
the nomenclature and the neologisms and
stuff like that to be able to describe
it which now you know it's evolved to
the point where I am trying to have
words that describe its symbols that
describe but also I just want to
experientially like you know hold
someone's hand and drop in with them to
such a degree I - I where they
themselves begin to feel the nature of
the reality rather than using the
symbols and the the words that talk yeah
it's uh when you ask a lot of questions
you just learn so much and I think part
of asking great questions about great
topics is expanding you know mind
expansion and one way that shows the
fruits of that is that you're able to
explain things you weren't you didn't
used to be able to explain right you
have the language to describe things and
obviously as we get into very high-level
metaphysics of that things become very
symbolic and it's just allegory and
symbolism ultimately as we get kind of
codes of reality but when you become
more of a philosopher within self you
become linguistically better at
describing things so I think all of us
are hopefully doing that process event
through our part are going through those
processes of it and that's beautifully
said you so I'm just gonna ask you about
themes that have been you mentioned
these reoccurring themes that have woven
through the show over the years and I
think you you've already highlighted
that through hopefully a rack and I at
least as some of your guests have helped
you spiritualize the show oh my gosh yes
that's such an important point is that
we sit on the shoulders of giants and
now if we if we truly humble ourselves
and drop our egos to the truth of the
interconnectedness of all then we
realize that we are a product of the of
the one of all they all of that deep
interconnectedness so every single one
of these brilliant people that we've had
sit on the program especially people
like you guys are the Giants that make
my worldview what it is
yeah nuts it you know
he goes into it but I just mean it
seemed there's so much bad spirituality
out there out there and when you get
into this people that have had
experiences the Spirit resonates and
know it having a feeling of knowing that
you're what you're hearing is authentic
and seeing that in people as your
discernment gets better you know finding
some random person who may not be famous
but they wrote some book on the greater
ecology of the rainforest or something
then you read their words in their
material and it's like it resonates it
pulls at your heartstrings so I just
mean in the sense that you've had many
guests that have led you into matters of
greater spirit what what are some
examples of bed spirituality may Isis
such a thing okay great segue okay I've
been I've been trying to I've been
trying to actually make make make this
into um we were talking about the
importance of visualization to help with
this if you imagine the yin and yang and
if you take the the white side and you
make the white side of spirituality and
you make the black side science and on
the white side of spirituality you have
and let's just start with this that the
one itself is the truth but within the
one is great models in the yin and yang
are one of those great models within the
one that helped us understand the
perfection okay science is spirit right
we've done a couple we did a short clip
recently on our channel about the
perfectness of good and evil right about
the yin yang of good and evil okay now
let's do the science of spear one on the
white side you have spirituality within
spirituality you have this little black
dot and that little black dot is science
and it's the way that science actually
helps spirituality and I'll give you
this example bad spirituality is when
someone sells snake oil
that's bad spirituality and then science
helps with the process of making sure
that what spirituality is teaching is
actually whatever it can try and
quantify right whatever can quantify is
trying to do its best to assist with the
process of showing the the great
successes and Ben
and efficacies and love that
spirituality can cascade on the science
side science also has on its black side
it has a little white dot in it that
little white dot of spirituality what
science has in its fuck-ups is things
like when you unlock the power of the
cell or the atom around 1953 what you
have is both the code of life and
biology which is great but you also have
engineering biological malevolence --is
you also have you unlock potential for
for the fusion of atoms like the Sun to
give us free energy but you also have
the power to make a nuclear bomb and so
what spirituality does in that science
side is it enables us to ethically
morally philosophically understand where
science should not be applied which is
in malevolence is in Jeannette in
biological engineering nuclear bombs
right those are just two of the examples
but so that's how I've started to also
see it and I think it can if if viewed
that way those two can kind of harmonize
in gel where they're learning from each
other and growing and ascending together
well one thing too is you you have out
shoots which is similar to us where
through many conversations you pull away
themes and then you have your own pieces
that you pull away from those themes
like your talk on you know things not
being binary and oversimplifications of
things there's a lot of dynamics where
many people do these superhero titles on
some massive entire system being just
purely bad or something you know saying
that science alone is XYZ at this and
you know ABC at that or vice-versa with
religion and oftentimes think of
something like magic which is the aim of
speaking of religion using the methods
of science you know there's so many
areas of gray with so many things and a
lot of things are very simple but also
have a lot of nuance and subtleties and
life is very gradient of gray it's not
just all black and white like the yin
yang yin yang shows so yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's it's really neat to see your
process do it in your evolution because
I I think that there's nothing quite
like growing through the process of
talking to people and then having a body
of knowledge and insight that then you
share either through future
conversations or in solo ways through
your talks and using your skillset of
having past organizations with other
people and your networks to be a speaker
in with continuing things that resonate
with you
you know topics that you pull out of the
show as it goes forward it evolves I
understand myself this show the guests
the nature of reality all these things
better because people like you say Allen
I would like to take my time out of my
life to also interview you and ask you
questions and so it just helps my
worldview and understanding when you do
so yeah man thank you man yeah
absolutely but we'll wrap it up here I
have one more question after us
questions you guys talked about the the
name of the show and this simulation is
the will Allen's show that this
recurrence time of this recording is
called simulation and I'm gonna ask him
the question are we in assuming because
Allen Wade witnessed autonomous agents
of the divine intelligence that are
having this interface with you but we're
not really here we're not where you're
ain't where are your gain JAL's on your
shoulders and you know that words are
scotch all those thousand interviews
you've done they're not really there
right there all you merrily merrily
merrily roll one deep pregnant pause not
afraid he's a man that's not afraid to
have a nice mature silence so many
people are scared of silence is to in
conversation it's like being at some
blind date and being terrified of
silence you know that's another aspect
of kind of immaturity within
communication great catch what's your
insulin how many have you asked most
people if we're in a simulation every
single one what's been takeaways from
this answer there are a series of
answers he's laughing smiling for those
not watching my video um have you been
asked this question you've asked this a
thousand times how many times has it
been asked to you are we to sensation a
couple times come the answers evolved
over time I definitely would probably
just recommend my perspective is very
close that answer is very close to the
episode that we did with Rach Oz Mariana
T fairy on all is one simulation theory
if you guys look up that episode on our
channel also in simulation theory that
one will give you a pretty good idea of
how it's pretty athlete or the other
about what my thoughts are and it's such
an incredible episode that my thoughts
became more clear on it by the
roundtable we had with those four and so
that's just this classic process of
building up Who I am and how I think and
how I feel about it so it feels like if
if we could try and you know use like
fun words to try and understand the
nature of the reality and use the word
simulation in it I like learning
simulation yeah that's well said man
learning lab yeah stuff like that it's
kind of fun so that's what cuz every
coach's had you know samsara illusion
Maya it's not that it's not real it's
just that it's not the only real it's a
real that's embedded in a larger real
and that if you identify with the player
in the game you're not really getting
what it is and then the choice you have
to play that game in to contribute as
you said to the Indian your being not
just to be happy but to be adding
something it's aggregating this
simulation its own self-awareness its
own self knowledge and so in self
evolution yes you told me to say that is
that rapper yeah where can people find
you but where can they locate only in
the mirror network of the internet tubes
yes yes the best place to find more on
all these things that we discussed is a
simulation series.com also
youtube-dot-com forward-slash simulation
series if you want to follow on
instagram it's also simulation series on
twitter it's simulation show so go and
follow these types of things if you want
to check out the general website for
myself it's alan sake on comm my first
name last name comm and that's also this
my same handle across social platforms
if you want to follow there and also for
those that we're watching on on our show
go and check out both nyle segments
common rockers am calm check out the
shamans of the global village also their
series we just did another episode that
was talking about their second episode
that's launching in spring 2020 so that
link again is also in the bio for you
guys and thank you for having me on this
has been super family on both sides of
the mic isn't it cuz I got and sometimes
as an interviewer you will know more
than the person you're interviewing so
it's nice to sometimes be flipped and be
able to answer questions right when
you're solely asking
it's nice to not always be on only one
side of the mic to have it bounce back
and forth creates a nice body of work in
that regard yeah I think we cherish like
you like you said Alan I mean we cherish
these conversations and what you're
doing is a nice platform of an archive
of great long-form things and in 2018 I
made rec and I we talk about this on the
drive down I made a conscious effort to
try and abandon most short-form things
just because it's so ephemeral and
you're not gonna care about your Twitter
feed when you're in the nursing home
there's a good way of using some of
those feeds as tools to get information
out and disseminate them in self market
but ultimately you know we really like
longer form things like great
conversation you can post all those an
archive do it before after you you know
before you croak and they'll always be
there yes yeah that's a nice body of
work however you do it and and and
another thing if you if you think about
this you're like many of your most
profound experiences in your life
regarding stories that other people told
you we're in the format of like like JK
Rowling and like Harry Potter like a
multi book multi-year saga investment
same thing with Star Trek Star Wars
multi-year fan clubs movies books right
so when it comes to something like the
dissemination of the nature of reality
to awakening and what I'm honing in my
skills on for this next chapter that I
will be following a similar paradigm of
the greats in terms of storytelling like
that yeah good yeah
fiction is great to translate real
information love you guys thank you for
having me this has been a pleasure
thanks everyone for tuning in
let us know your thoughts in the
comments below I'd love to hear from you
and we'll see you soon
much love sweet buddy we were exactly 57
minutes all right cool